signe que les produits de niche et du
terroir ont la cote petit à petit des
produits agroalimentaires québécois
bénéficie d'une appellation certifié
pour les producteurs c'est une façon de
se démarquer dans un marché souvent très
compétitif le nouveau venu le fromage
fermier
[Musique]
à saint roch ouest dans lanaudière la
famille dit elle possède un troupeau de
chèvres
se le festi beauguitte elle qui a la
charge les 420 bête
12 bonne race laitière là ça ne fait qu
ils achètent toute blanche on voit ici
et l'alpine
et tout ce qui est colorée donc on a
différentes robes on anaky chamoisé on
en a qui les coûts clair on en a qui
pratiquement tous trois les pattes
blanches c'est une autre robe qu'on
appelle 100 go
pour lui la qualité du lait dépend de la
santé de ses ennemis et à la base tous
les cool des aliments aux produits de a
à z le pot pour fois nourrir notre peau
donc des cartes fourragère de bonne
qualité après ça des petits rial notre
avoine qui va servir à
le guen va servir à alimenter nos démos
et la faille va servir à l'est
[Musique]
toute la production laitière du troupeau
sert à fabriquer du fromage et c'est à
la même adresse
thibault et ses trois soeurs ont repris
l'entreprise mis sur pied par leurs
parents legit elles sont à la fois
producteurs de lait et fromage est
dorénavant en vertu d'une nouvelle
réglementation de québec adopté en
décembre 2021 ils peuvent afficher sur
leur fromage fromage fermier un terme à
l'horizon
l'idée c'est d'être capable d'assurer
intensité du présumé d'assurer des
consommateurs qui recherchent un produit
authentique fait selon des méthodes
traditionnelles qui fait avec le lait
d'un troupeau que l'exploitant exploite
lui même il faut je donne les outils aux
consommateurs pour trouver ce produit
voici le logo qui distingue le fromage
fermier qui illustre l'esprit du
règlement
une ferme un troupeau et au fromage et
l'entreprise de guitl ce qu elle lui fit
on a pris ce n'est là que pour paris
lille après et puis on va mettre des
ferments de l'après jeux pour le
transformer en fromage
on
magali fabrique aujourd'hui la
chevronnée leurs chèvres à succès
mais le fromage fermier peut-être fait
de lait de vache de chèvre de brebis ou
de bufflonne biologique ou
conventionnelle les crues terme usées ou
pas ce taux de 6
comme le fermier fromager doit être
maître d'oeuvre le règlement défend des
opérations par ordinateur
le fun de le transformer à chaque fois
pour avoir toujours le même résultat
bien que le lait soit échangeant bien
que là les saisons soit et changeante
tout seul ça fait des beaux défis
quotidiens mais c'est
passionnant
il a fallu des années de démarches avant
que le ministère de l'agriculture en
viennent à réglementer et finalement
c'est une grande fierté pour rue
d'afficher le nouveau logo on a beaucoup
d'espoir dans ces termes là ça va nous
différencier aussi des fromages
industriels qu'on retrouve qui peuvent
dans un comptoir de fromage être très
similaires à des fromages fermiers on va
apprendre à faire la différence
petit moyen ou grand transformateur ne
peuvent plus employer l'expression
fromages fermiers librement le terme est
réservé c'est sur vos frères faire le
ménage à des tiers parce que ceux
aujourd'hui qui vont pouvoir utiliser le
thème fromages fermiers blancs vont
devoir être celle ci
contrairement à la grande industrie la
race des animaux le terroir les
fourrages le savoir-faire de la
fromagère enfants te fromage unique
s'ils viennent de mettre bas ils
viennent d'avoir des bébés iront
beaucoup plus de lait et on est beaucoup
plus riches alors que quand on va
bientôt les tarir le lait et yahia qui a
possiblement différents éléments de d'un
alors ça fait en sorte qu'on doit
toujours jouer sur la quantité de lait
pour faire un fromage 250 g on n'y
arrive pas toujours
[Musique]
des pays comme la france et la suisse
qui possède un très grand nombre de
modes de valorisation
garantissant l'origine et la qualité des
produits pour guider la rédaction du
règlement
health in québec le producteur de lait
fromage et doit s'en tenir à une ferme
de taille moyenne limitée à 2 millions
de litres transformé par année on a
envie de croire à l'éducation qui va
être fait autour de cette appellation là
pour que le consommateur leur
reconnaissent et que sa levée vraiment
dire quelque chose pour pour le
consommateur quand il retrouve ce logo
dans le comptoir à l'épicerie
[Musique]
le conseil des industriels laitiers du
québec assume la promotion du nouveau
termes valorisants auprès du public et
des fromagers fermiers un logo qui sera
profitable pour tous croient son
directeur et sosh pense que c'est bon
parce que c'est moi je sache peut être
prête à payer plus cher pour ces
critères qui sait ce combat
legit elle ne fabrique pas que du
fromage de chèvre la moitié de la
production fromagère effet de lait de
vache vite faire sauter du lait de vache
ce set initial
c'est comme ça chez nous on transforme à
deux types de ligue
[Musique]
depuis 1997 legit elle achète le lait
des vaches de leurs voisins près de 300
mille litres cette année vaches et
chèvres sont nourris au même point les
deux voisins élèvent leurs animaux de
manière semblable
or le fromage fermier doit être produit
exclusivement avec le lait du troupeau
de la ferme ce fromage de vache échappe
donc à la certification
à toutes les étapes on a en indy car on
y travaille on réfléchit à ce qu'on fait
quand le fait correctement c'est clair
que y'a tout la même fierté que ce soit
se transforme le lait de vache de
yannick ou que je transforme les chefs
de montfort beau je suis tout aussi fier
du résultat
dans la même logique sont exclus du
terme valorisante toutes les fromageries
qui complètent leur production en
achetant du lait d'autres producteurs
laitiers
[Musique]
il s'agit du premier termes valorisants
qu'accorde le gouvernement provincial
québec vrai l organisme accrédité qui
garantit l'authenticité du produit
l'adhésion est aux frais du producteur
jusqu'à 60 fermiers fromager pourrait-il
y avoir droit c'est ce qu'en termes
d'importance de lait transformés si je
regarde juste le lait de vache les
trente producteurs transformateurs
peut-être collectivement vont
transformer en 15 et 20 millions de
litres de lait ce qui représente à peu
près points 5 % du lait transformé 1 re
au québec donc ce marché de niche
cette nouvelle appellation arrive au
moment où les récents accords
commerciaux prévoit l'entrée au pays de
produits laitiers l'étranger
notamment dix sept mille tonnes de
fromages européens le fait d'avoir le
beau fromage fermier moi je pense que ça
va aider encore plus au consommateur à
faire la distinction entre produits
d'ici qui fromages fermiers donc qu'un
authenticité versus l'importation
différence
[Musique]
autre atout face à la concurrence le
terme fromages fermiers réfère aux
territoires de fabrication et un
sentiment d'appartenance des
consommateurs par rapport à la
fromagerie qui a fabriqué le fromage et
c'est souvent une fromagerie familiale
donc elle est établie dans le coin on
connaît les gens mais les fromages et
les fermiers
des fois personnellement aussi
[Musique]
moins car j'ai mes deux pieds des
bottines ce côté de la ferme ont parlé -
dalton qui a oublié pas plus ferme y
exxon
savoir-faire pour le pain
encore au jeu pour le fils
[Musique]
et bonne nouvelle pour les fromagers
fermiers le conseil des industriels
laitiers du québec et le ministère de
l'agriculture vont assumer 75% du
montant de la certification pour la
première année d'adhésion d'autres
négociations sont nécessaires pour la
suite